our proposals as you know we were given
promises
not to move nato infrastructure to the
east
not a single inch
eastwards
you all know that you all are well aware
and now we see where missiles are
pollen romania
bounty countries
so they said one thing they did another
thing
as our people
say so we were basically swindled
we were lied to
okay okay that's fine
and then the united states withdrew from
the entire missile defense treaty
we tried to convince them not to do this
it was one of the fundamental agreements
about the global security nevertheless
the united states did what they did they
withdrew from it and now
the missile launch system
in
romania and in poland they're going to
be there soon if not already there yet
and there are mk-41 launchers
and you can
deploy tomahawks there so it's not
anti-missiles these are strike systems
that are going to cover our territory
thousand kilometers deep
is this not a threat to us
now they say that the next step is
ukraine so they must
approve it
to join
nato so listen to me listen to me
carefully
in ukrainian doctrines it says that they
want to
take back crimea
and
if they have to they will use military
force that so these are not just work
that's part of their doctrine
now let's assume that ukraine is the
nato state so they are pumped with
weapon they have modern offensive
weapons like they do it in poland in
europe and now they start an operation
in crimea
i'm not even talking about
the donkeys here that's the sovereign
russian territory
so it's uh
non-starter for us
so let's imagine that ukraine is a nato
state and they start the separation so
now do we have to
start the war against the nato
alliance did anyone think about that i
don't think so